president biden is not on the ballot
today in virginia but boy are the
democrats letting it be known how
embarrassed they are of the guy a new
poll finds 44 percent of voters in his
party want somebody other than biden to
be the 2024 nominee earlier while
overseas biden tried to spin his
leadership as a success
if you take a look at what what economy
is growing
the united states
is growing this thanksgiving we're all
in a very different circumstance
things are a hell of a lot better
and
the wages have gone up higher faster
than inflation
and we have generated real economic
growth
as bad as things are in terms of prices
helping
hurting families now trade this
thanksgiving for last thanksgiving
harold wages aren't keeping up with
inflation in this country before we move
on the fox we have the voter analysis
you're going to see on the side of your
screen some from the elections today so
keep an eye on that but listen put your
listening ears on as judge judy would
say wages are not keeping up with
inflation and inflation is running
according to one gauge at the fastest
pace in
30 years harold
so i think that voters are concerned as
i am and you are about inflation i don't
know how much voters are giving him or
assigning all the blame to biden and all
to blame those policies i think the
supply chain is having an impact on this
democrats kind of lose their sense of
humor about things they're very reactive
people i'm one of them uh they they're
frustrated right now with the fact that
uh he can't seem to referee and
reconcile differences between the
moderates and progressives so
they're expressing themselves but i'll
tell you if we sit here tomorrow and you
invite me back at some point and the new
jersey race goes democrat the virginia
waste goes democrat you get eric adams
as mayor here in new york which is
likely to happen and he really ushers in
a public safety platform that changes
the the construct and direction of the
city and they pass something in the
house in the senate here in the next
week or so the numbers will probably go
go back up but i don't i don't i don't
quarrel with you but as you and i both
know you don't give all the credit to
this but the s p the dow and the nasdaq
all closed the record today the dow
close above 36 000 you get on me a
little bit but i'm a capitalist democrat
and i think those things are important
for the country to be able to grow and
it's important even for this president
if a republican president i'd be
celebrating these numbers and i think we
ought to give him credit for uh being at
least a part of this story gigi
well first of all i love the gigi maybe
yeah that was my nickname when i danced
you know i was super spreader well that
was
that was in the low days when i had to
make money the hard way you know i want
to say
i was just thinking that de blasio filed
for to run for governor from new york
right didn't he yesterday so that's i
mean that's scarier than any of this but
anyway so the 44 of democrats wanted one
another nom uh want another person
besides biden you have to remind
yourself that the number was probably
higher when he was actually running but
they said
just get in
and we'll figure it out later so this is
actually i think for the democrats this
is part of the plan right uh they never
said we love joe and we're gonna stick
with him until 2024. they just wanted
him to get into the door and then
replace him when he falls apart which
could be in a year could be less than a
year the problem is the backup
quarterback that they have sucks and
they need a new one they expected that
they were getting like a youthful joe
montana instead they got a todd
maranovich huh yeah how's that sports
people that sports you're pulling out
marinovich that's excellent you know who
he is right yes i do
he was one of them what did i say
no you said i'm with you tom
west coast man yeah remember his dad
crazy yeah i
i have nowhere to go with that
jesse cause again we're getting to a
long conversation about the marina [ __ ]
clan
yeah no i i don't want to engage in a
sports conversation with gutfeld that's
gonna go nowhere but this is a political
reference this is a polar democrat so i
have to put my democrat thinking cap on
i have to slouch and frown and be
jealous of gutfeld's vast wealth
and so the democrats i know because i
know democrats they want power that is
the most important thing and so this
poll acknowledges that they don't think
joe biden can win re-election and they
think his presidency so far is costing
them power in the house democrats
obviously want their agenda enacted and
so far joe biden has not really been
effective at enacting their agenda and
lastly democrats want to be inspired
that's why democrats usually vote for
the guy that sends a thrill down their
leg you know bubba or barack is joe
biden inspiring democrats no he can
barely make it through a speech that's
in the teleprompter so he's boring he's
ineffective and he's threatening their
hold on power that is the reason why
democrats are fleeing like this so
significantly and can i fact check him
one more time yes he's comparing this
thanksgiving the last thanksgiving we're
actually averaging more covid19 deaths
today than we averaged last year same
time and same amount of cases
so things have not gotten better in
terms of coping with joe biden on that
metric yeah and the truth is that that
joe biden is losing on education he's
losing on the coronavirus in addition to
that the democrats as you say jesse are
not inspired then you've got a scenario
where the guy falls asleep at an
international conference where and then
he shows up at a climate conference that
we'll talk about later you know with 85
car motorcade everything he does is
inconsistent with his message he can't
keep his own party together everyone's
disappointed in him and the and you know
kamala harris they've got nowhere to go
with her so you know they're like
they're they're totally frustrated with
their own party and the truth is that
when you've got mansion coming out and
saying that he's playing all kinds of
shell games and he's got all kinds of
budget gimmicks nobody's buying anything
that this man is selling nothing of what
he's selling is positive or anyone wants
to engage in well the only reason he was
elected was to not be president trump in
style but not substance exactly just in
style and instead he comes in and
immediately because again the
republicans lost in georgia and
immediately started referring to lbj and
fdr yeah and that that's not what people
elected him to quite frankly we'd be a
lot better off as a country if he was
asleep all the time yeah but then who's
running the country do you know the
american people the american people yes
but what about schools
they take them over they pull their kids
out when greg tomorrow okay we're all
doing this together okay i don't have
kids so i'm not allowed to do that but i
do i've tried if we were on that tesla
autopilot we'd be in good shape
nationwide